there ted is standing by ted the kids
had uh one of those soccer games where
there's not a tree in sight near the
park on saturday midday whoo that was
hot out there and you're saying that
heat gonna continue yeah that park needs
to have a big pool i was looking for a
tree anyway where's some shades so
excessive heat warnings were issued this
weekend was a good big pool weekend and
of course the heat warnings still remain
brian all the way until 8 o'clock
tonight so they were extended the good
news to that however is the heat warning
will not be extended that's going to be
over and done with as we drop back to
the 90s but your humidity goes up off in
the distance there if you look towards
the east you can see these big clouds
out here those are storms off into
arizona right now 96 degrees at the
south is your current temperatures
humidity at 19 percent dew point at 47.
those are all going to go up as we get
through tomorrow and also on wednesday
no rain today unfortunately no rain for
the month in fact we should be at three
tenths of an inch for this time of the
year here's where we're at almost an
inch and four tenths but this is where
we should be right now for this time of
year so any raindrops are needed we're
still in monsoon season all the way
until mid to late september right the
century mark for sky canyon in
centennial hills
99 for nellis 100 for whitney ranch
double nines for henderson and mountains
edge at 97 along with roads ranch and
again we'll always switch up our
neighborhoods for you every newscast so
nobody's left down 100 for indian
springs 102 for laughlin 101 for boulder
city so there are the clouds of us right
now
no rain over us but we are tracking
these storms out here often just north
of dolan springs that will be heading
into eastern portions of clark county
some storms in california this hour and
of course in arizona that's where all
the action is zooming out the remnants
of what was once tropic or i should say
hurricane hurricane nora it's died out
this is its carcass all its remnant
activity out here will be drawn up by an
area of low pressure and pulled into our
region tomorrow and also wednesday in
fact our best chances are going to be in
arizona again but we still keep those
isolated straight chances for us here
all the way up to lincoln county for
these next few days futurecast does show
tonight not much
chance for any big storms tonight here
but we could see them pick up again
tomorrow there's four o'clock tomorrow
around southern nevada and also for the
evening hours too
also on wednesday just chances of
wednesday look at that but better
chances tomorrow overnight 84 degrees
partly cloudy skies we're looking at
mainly light winds for tonight your high
tomorrow 100 degrees partly cloudy it's
going to be humid tomorrow we have those
chances of thunderstorms i just
pinpointed out to you on our future cast
highs tomorrow close to 100 a lot of you
in the high 90s tomorrow so still a hot
day for tomorrow a little humid too
but out of the excessive heat thankfully
highs outside the valley right on 114
for death valley hot for you for sure 98
in boulder city 104 for laflip here's
your eight day forecast we'll keep those
chances of storms around through
wednesday after that the second half of
the week drier will still be in those
high 90s to right near the century mark
and then next week look at that partly
cloudy skies for labor day and still
more that's your most accurate forecast
denise how are you